Olá minhas amigas meus amigos para mais
um vídeo aqui Dr aland Dutra falando
vamos fazer algo bem diferente hoje eu
vou reagir a um vídeo a uma entrevista
de um podcast entrevistou uma doutora
bioquímica de nome jessin CSP eu achei
bem interessante essa entrevista e
resolvi fazer aqui umas colocações da
maioria das coisas que ela disse eu
concordo bastante e eu quero aqui
pontuar só algumas coisas que eu não
concordo e eu vou dar opinião bem
fundamentada bem basada porque eu não
concordo com esses pontos da entrevista
e esta bioquímica lançou um best seller
que tá vendendo bastante não sei se na
Europa ou nos Estados Unidos Mas vamos
aos pontos aqui que é discutido nessa
entrevista bem a fanne desse vídeo já é
bastante chamativa coloca assim você não
precisa fazer dieta você pode comer o
que você você quiser isso é colocado na
thumbnail como se fosse um clickbait
Apesar desse clickbait você vai observar
ao longo desse vídeo que a autora de
fato tem ótimas ideias sobre nutrição e
que são fundamentalmente corretas Mas
ela tem aí uma certa fridão ela é um
pouco liberal em alguns aspectos e já
vamos chegar nesse ponto primeiro porque
existem tantos métodos estratégias
dietas técnicas sobre alimentação
nutrição saúde e bem-estar que acredito
que causam mais mal do que bem as
pessoas por serem tão restritivos mas
uma das primeiras páginas do seu livro
fala como isso não é sobre uma dieta
restritiva não é dieta ou modismo é
entender como o corpo funciona e quando
comer carboidratos e causar menos
Impacto é sobre saúde sem restrições
pode comer o que quiser por exemplo mas
você provavelmente não vai querer
consumir açúcar em excesso todo dia
Class o açúcar nos prejudica certo
provoca picos de glicose inflamação
envelhecimento e liberação de insulina
porém restrição não é a solução para o
ambiente alimentar atual ela
Desconsidera as diferentes
particularidades de pacientes em
diferentes situações então eu como
médico é diferente de você tá com
biólogo como bioquímico como algum
profissional que não tem contato direto
no dia a dia com pessoas com situações
aí particulares de saúde na condição de
bioquímica e autora de livro e não
médica ela já se pode dar a esse luxo de
dar orientações genéricas doos pacientes
e esperar aí que como se todos vão
reagir de forma igual Então apesar de
várias das ideias dela estarem corretas
ela no meu ponto de vista Desconsidera
as difer diferentes particularidades de
pacientes particularidades bioquímicas
diferentes situações diferentes doenças
de base uma das alegações ao longo do
vídeo é que você ser entre aspas muito
restritivo restritiva isso causa mais
mal do que bem então essa restrição
causaria assim um desespero na pessoa
que não conseguiria e seguir as
orientações essa é uma argumentação
muito utilizada dentro desse contexto de
falso bom senso que pode funcionar muito
bem para uma pessoa dita normal que não
tem uma doença crônica mas que não vai
funcionar bem para uma pessoa que tem
uma situação uma doença de base
importante como uma grande resistência
insulínica pré-diabetes diabetes então
recapitulando pessoas que TM alguma
doença de base grave um diabetes uma
doença neurodegenerativa você não ser
tão restritivo você fazer uma coisa
muito suave de mudança estilo de vida
não vai ter o impacto necessário para
que você possa mudar realmente a
evolução da sua doença e quanto com uma
pessoa que não tem uma doença de base
tem apenas aí uma necessidade de
emagrecimento esse dito bom senso que se
diz essa situação que não vai ser muito
restritiva Pode sim ser o suficiente
para essa pessoa dita normal restrição
não é a solução para o ambiente
alimentar atual eu não acredito nisso
acho que você pode tentar isso por uma
semana dizendo Este ano não vou comer
açúcar mas não funciona nunca funciona
então recomendo que Experimente algumas
dessas técnicas se quer comer açúcar um
biscoito um doce ou algo assim o melhor
momento para extrair o máximo prazer e
Minimizar impactos no corpo é após uma
refeição como sobremesa evite consumir
em jejum ou pela manhã sério sim o café
da manhã deve ser salgado nada de doce
sério sim os doces com chocolate por
dentro ou um bolinho de manhã deixe para
a sobremesa após o almoço comer isso
pela manhã faz com que o açúcar e os
carboidratos se convertam rapidamente em
glicose na corrente sanguínea causando
pico glicêmico então em certos momentos
do vídeo ela dá várias dicas comuns que
já damos há muitos anos de melhoria de
estilo de vida ela reconhece os
problemas de saúde comuns relacionados
ao açúcar mas diz que a restrição não é
a solução as pessoas simplesmente não
teriam força de vontade e não
conseguiriam seguir as medidas então ela
dá a dica de só comer açúcar depois de
uma refeição como uma sobremesa não
tomar o açúcar ou alimento açucarado de
manhã ou em jejum e o café da manhã
somente utilizar alimentos salgados
nunca comer também açúcar como Lanche ou
de estômago vazio e nunca consumir os
carboidratos puros nesses pontos eu
concordo plenamente com a autora eu acho
que ela foi muito feliz e ter frisado
nisso Apesar de que ela diz Ah não você
pode comer o que você quiser com tanto
que você deixe para comer o doce depois
do almoço como sobremesa aí eu posso
dizer para vocês Depende se for uma
pessoa normal metabolicamente falando
não for um diabético alguém com uma
doença crônica importante
pode ser totalmente válido isso daí você
pode deixar para comer um sorvete depois
do almoço e você não vai ter um impacto
metabólico tão grande agora um paciente
portador de Alzheimer ou um diabético eu
nunca recomendaria comer doce depois do
almoço e esse pessoal precisa ter sim
muito mais restrição do que uma pessoa
que não tem essas doenças seus níveis de
Açúcar vão cair causando uma queda
brusca que agora são 10 horas 11 horas
da manhã e de repente você sente mais
vontade de comidas doces você está tipo
eu preciso de um biscoito eu preciso de
chocolate eu preciso de um doce preciso
disso e depois vem outro pico então você
passa o dia numa montanha russa se
sentindo viciado em açúcar quando se
enfrenta uma queda de glicose após um
pico o centro de desejos no cérebro
ativa e diz Luis coma um biscoito você
quer evitar isso porque depois não vai
conseguir lutar contra isso no seu
cérebro Sim esse centro é muito poderoso
e está ligado a respostas que temos para
baixo nível de açúcar no sangue por isso
você quer evitar que isso aconteça o que
ela fala dos efeitos do pico de glicose
no organismo né o efeito da glicação E
também o efeito inflamatório do açúcar é
perfeito só que ela oferece uma solução
simples demais que seria para englobar
todos isso não vai funcionar para quem
tem experiência de atendimento para quem
atende pacientes no dia a dia porque o
que parece bom senso e comedimento para
uns e que pode ser suficiente para
normalizar os níveis de insulina de
glicose de pessoas assim com leve
resistência insulínica para outra pessoa
com uma doença mais grave pode ser
simplesmente
insuficiente eu cansei de ver isso na
minha prática clínica então se fosse
assim se qualquer dieta e com o mínimo
de bom senso fosse suficiente Por que
então propor uma dieta restritiva como a
dieta ketogenica ketoflex para quem tem
Alzheimer porque essa pessoa já tem uma
resistência sínica cerebral um
pré-diabetes cerebral e não vai adiantar
pedir para essa pessoa comer sorvete
depois do almoço isso não vai ser o
suficiente Apesar que a altura não é
especializada nessa doença específica e
ela também não é uma profissional que
atenda pacientes fica claro aqui que as
orientações delas podem ser muito úteis
para um grupo de pessoas que não têm
doenças crônicas mas que não vai
funcionar para esses grupos específicos
Então por que que não pode ser somente
bom senso porque essa pessoa que tem
doença crônica que já tem um grau de
resistência insulínica importante no
caso do Alzheimer uma resistência
insulínica cerebral ela já não é uma
pessoa comum que pode se dar ao Luxo de
estratégia de senso comum então a gente
tem que ficar muito claro para vocês
para vocês não caírem na falácia do
falso equivalente de que tudo é muito
fácil para todo mundo sobre o jejum
quero lembrar que o intermitente não é
necessário para ter um corpo saudável
não é necessário jejuar para ser
saudável comer bem para a manter a
glicos estável é mais importante que
restringir as horas de alimentação
especialmente para mulheres Vale lembrar
que o jejum é um estressor corporal
então se você já tem uma vida
estressante crianças para cuidar insônia
consome café pratica intensos exercícios
cardiovasculares toma banhos frios
adicionar jejum a isso é algo muito
stress para o seu corpo lidar e é por
isso que você vê algumas mulheres
sobrecarregando todas essas coisas seus
hormônios estão deteriorando elas se
sentem exaustas o tempo todo o corpo
delas Está simplesmente dizendo não é
muito estresse eu amo jejum quando estou
de férias por exemplo e parece um
estresse fácil de suportar mas quando
estou trabalhando e fazendo muita as
coisas prefiro tomar café da manhã ter
um café da manhã saboroso como expliquei
para manter meu nível de glicose estável
e simplesmente comer três vezes no dia
aí em certo momento no vídeo também ela
diz não é preciso jejuar para ter níveis
de glicose saudáveis E a minha resposta
quanto a isso é sim e não algumas
pessoas não vão precisar realmente fazer
jejum para atingir os níveis ideais de
glicose no sangue porém algumas pessoas
sim vão precisar do jejum para acelerar
o processo de cura para ter os melhores
resultados Comer bem é mais importante
do que restringir as horas de
alimentação outra afirmação que ela faz
sim sem dúvida Comer bem é muito mais
importante do que a restrição de horas
do tal jejum intermitente Mas isso não
anula o poder de associar as duas
estratégias o que vai tornar tudo muito
mais poderoso Então por que você vai
deixar de fazer um jejum intermitente
simplesmente porque a sua dieta já está
razoável ou boa não faria sentido você
tá desprezando uma excelente estratégia
simplesmente porque Teoricamente só a
mudança alimentar seria bom o suficiente
o que pode não ser para vários pacientes
uma das alegações dela é que o jejum
provoca estresse muitas pessoas e esse
estresse poderia desregular o cortisol
especialmente mulheres isso faz todos
sentido eu concordo que se o jejum
parece ser excessivamente difícil de ser
feito ele deve ser cessado imediatamente
e tentado em algum outro momento mas não
é porque a pessoa não tá adaptada paraa
cetose ela não está ainda fazendo uma
dieta com restrição de carboidrato
suficiente e por isso ela acaba ficando
mais estressada em jejum ela pode
simplesmente parar de fazer o jejum e
tentar de novo em outro momento mas é
sabido que muitas pessoas conseguem
ficar em jejum mesmo mulheres e não
ficam estressados o tempo todo por isso
então se acontecer realmente da pessoa
não conseguir fazer sem ser um tormento
Total ela deixa para fazer um outro
momento ela faz uma adaptação para
alguma outra etapa da vida dela que ela
se sinta mais adaptada se sinta mais
apropriada para fazer o jejum as quatro
dicas no meu o segundo livro são café da
manhã salgado em vez de doce vinagre
antes de comer carboidratos e um início
de refeição com vegetais você começa
suas refeições com vegetais e se
movimenta depois de comer então ela
passa a falar das quatro dicas que ela
dá no livro para ter saúde e várias
dessas dicas nós já falamos aqui no
canal Então vou concordar com a grande
maioria delas ela fala de um café da
manhã sem nada doce apenas salgado
perfeito é só tirarem aí os Car hidratos
refinados mesmo os salgados eu não
comeria por exemplo de manhã cedo um
arroz branco isso eu acho que não é uma
boa ideia para boa parte das pessoas se
for uma uma atleta se for uma pessoa que
faz atividade física regular pode comer
a vontade de um arz branco mas tem que
tomar cuidado boa parte das pessoas vai
ter resistência insulínica outra coisa
que ela alega que nós cansamos de falar
aqui no canal que realmente é muito bom
todo mundo concorda é o vinagre e maçã
antes de comer carboidratos isso vai
ajudar bastante realmente a reduzir o
pico glicêmico antes de comer qualquer
tipo de carboidrato e ela também advoga
um início de refeição com vegetais isso
também vai ajudar muito porque os
vegetais TM as fibras e as fibras vão
retardar o processamento desses
carboidratos tanto a digestão quanto a
absorção dos carboidratos e outra dica
muito interessante também é se
movimentar depois de comer por pelo
menos 10 minutos também concordo
plenamente E ela diz que no caso
específico dela tratar o café da manhã
como qualquer outra refeição mudou
completamente a vida dela por quê Porque
as pessoas têm essa ideia fixa de que o
café da manhã é uma refeição especial
que se come algumas coisas que não se
comem nas outras refeições quando na
verdade deveria ser a refeição igual
praticamente do almoço e você não
deveria comer coisas doces de manhã
então ela A partir dessa epifania que
ela teve ela parou de comer coisas doces
de manhã e passou a encarar esse café da
manhã como qualquer outra refeição
comendo proteínas de alta qualidade
gorduras de alta qualidade e não comendo
doces isso É bem interessante e se a
maioria das pessoas tivessem essa visão
certamente mudaria a vida delas também
uma vez ao dia depois de uma refeição
use seus músculos por 10 minutos se
movimente caminhe se estique e pule você
pode gastar 10 minutos para limpar o
apartamento lavar louça dobrar roupas ou
fazer compras se você estiver
trabalhando e por isso impossibilitado
de se movimentar faça elevações de
panturrilha por 10 minutos embaixo da
mesa Essas são formas fáceis e simples
de incluir o movimento para que músculos
absorvam a glicose da refeição Ah se
você está assistindo um filme comendo um
sorvete delicioso você tem algumas
opções você pode comer um punhado de
amêndoas enquanto saboreia o sorvete
para adicionar uma cobertura SA ao
sorvete legal você poderia fazer uma
bebida de vinagre pegar um livro ou uma
garrafa de água depois de tomar o
sorvete você pode fazer algumas flexões
de bíceps enquanto assiste ao filme
ajudando seus músculos a absorver essa
glicose sempre existem soluções ela fala
também uma coisa que eu converso muito
com os pacientes que ganhar músculos
ajuda sim a metabolizar melhor a glicose
e evitar a resistência insulínica então
você que está escutando faça a
musculação porque vai ajudar você a usar
esse Açúcar da alimentação para o
músculo e isso vai deixar de fazer pico
glicêmico no seu sangue e aí o
entrevistador pergunta se eu for tomar
um sorvete noturno vendo televisão que
que você me dá como dica para eu
diminuir esse estrago Né uma mania aí de
americanos aí fic tomando sorvete vendo
filme À noite mas eu imagino que muitos
brasileiros também façam isso Apesar de
que eu nunca ter feito isso mas já fiz
foi comer pipoca vendo o filme então ela
dá como dica algumas coisas
interessantes que eu concordo como
acrescentar amêndoas ou nooses no
sorvete ingerir vinagre de maçã Se for
possível depois do sorvete fazer
exercícios aí com os bíceps ou mesmo
fazendo elevações de panturrilhas ou
flexões depois de tomar o o sorvete
apesar de achar que é um pouco
complicado alguém querer fazer flexão no
meio de filme né mas pelo menos fazer a
elevação de panturrilhas é uma coisa aí
viável de ser feita durante esse período
que você tá assistindo o filme então é
como se a ansiedade crônica também
causasse Picos de glicose é o que eu
acho Por exemplo eventos muito
específicos de estresse vão causar um
pico certo ansiedade crônica talvez eu
não sei mas temos que lembrar a
alimentação ainda é 90% do que causa
picos de glicose ou não mas você vai ver
que em situações sociis muito
estressantes Às vezes você pode ter um
desses Picos e também é comentado que o
estresse pode ser um grande gerador de
descontrole da glicose que é verdade
isso é muito importante gerenciar bem
esse estresse especialmente com
meditação
e tive uma experiência maluca usei um
monitor de glicose pela primeira vez em
um estudo piloto e Numa manhã durante um
episódio de
despersonalização vi que Ele registrou
um pico de glicose do café que eu tinha
acabado de comer eu Inclusive estava
comendo coisas doces naquele café da
manhã interessante e naquele momento eu
pensei meu Deus será que existe uma
conexão entre o que eu estou comendo e a
minha saúde
mental Nossa o que está acontecendo
Espera aí talvez o pico isso me deixou
fascinada tinha acabado de comer um
Donut no café da manhã Talvez esse pico
causasse algo no cérebro fazendo os
sintomas surgir mergulhei nas pesquisas
e descobri que não estava sozinha mesmo
sem ter diabetes certos Picos podem
afetar os neurônios causando confusão
mental ansiedade alterações hormonais
energia desejo e saúde das mitocôndrias
e aí ela conta um pouco da vida pessoal
dela que ela teve um grande acidente na
adolescência ela caiu aí de uma
cachoeira quebrou a coluna e devido aos
traumas tanto da queda e do processo da
cirurgia que ela sofreu ela teve
problema de saúde mental Então ela teve
despersonalização ela se olhava no
espelho e ela não reconhecia o próprio
rosto não reconhecia o próprio partes do
corpo dela então isso é uma coisa
bastante peculiar que ela conta na sua
história Durante a entrevista ela passou
8 anos sofrendo com essas crises de
despersonalização e para ela o grande
momento aí o grande eureca foi quando
ela começou a monitorar a glicose e
associou os picos de glicose que ela
tinha ao monitorar com aparelho de
monitoramento contínuo com a saúde
mental dela então os períodos que ela
tinha o pico de glicose eram os períodos
que ela tinha maior eh alteração mental
dessa
despersonalização E ela percebeu que ao
controlar os Picos de glicose isso
ajudou muito no controle dos sintomas
mentais ela se curou desses problemas
mentais através dessa monitorização
então a conclusão que ela chega Apesar
que ela não achou nenhum estudo fazendo
correlação entre níveis de glicose com
despersonalização ela achou vários
estudos assim como eu já achei fazendo a
correlação entre a glicose do sangue e
problemas como depressão e ansiedade
então ela afirma como eu já afirmei em
vários vídeos anteriores que o açúcar
sim inflama o cérebro Então você deve
evitar o máximo possível pico de açúcar
para não inflamar o seu cérebro então em
um certo momento ela também discute que
os níveis de glicose altos provocados
por leite de aveia café com açúcar sucos
que você tá ingerindo aí e que só não
tem a
fibra vão dar pico de açúcar no seu
sangue então ela fala que ela não
recomenda tomar esses sucos ou tomar
esse leite de aveia sim comer frutas
mesmo que as frutas modernas sejam
completamente diferentes das frutas
ancestrais que tinham muito menos
frutose o ambiente alimentar em que
vivemos é muito confuso tantas comidas
que comemos são tão ruim para nós tão
tóxicas estamos todos perdidos mas eu
entendo porque essas drogas tomaram
conta é porque estamos profundamente
perdidos e curiosamente na França o zen
pque não é um problema sério sim são
apenas cigarros certo não não mas as
pessoas perguntam remédios então você
não tem fome por quê acredito que na
América por existirem Mais Alimentos
processados nossos hormônios da Fome são
desregulados sentimos fome
constantemente sem sabermos como comer
melhor e também ela faz uma crítica
muito válida ao zenic porque o zenic
apesar de ser uma droga extremamente
famosa nos dias atuais e que tem
resultado sim o emque faz perder peso e
muitas vezes o efeito sanfona prevalece
A pessoa perde peso e volta a ganhar
peso de novo porém ao ganhar esse peso
ao voltar a ganhar esse peso a pessoa
somente volta a ganhar massa gorda então
no processo de emagrecimento com zinque
perdeu massa magra com massa gorda e ao
ter o efeito sanfona de voltarem a
engordar essa pessoa não recupera os
músculos junto que é muito ruim de uma
maneira metabolicamente falando porque é
muito mais difícil perder peso uma
segunda ou terceira vez muito obrigado
por ter assistido esse vídeo Não deixe
de dar o seu joinha nesse vídeo faça sua
pergunta aqui embaixo Deixe os
comentários eu vou tentar responder o
máximo que eu consegui e foi um prazer
conversar com vocês hoje um grande
abraço no coração de vocês vocês são
Fera